are up in that area up there
well well well what is this
oh what the hell
weird okay
oh i missed
[Music]
mark's dead again amber did you see
something on cams or something
somebody invented and they have a
hamster i don't know who it was
oh [ __ ] killed is that bloody bloody
do you have a hamster
nope he was a half turtle
we're gonna find guy i have a out
guy trevor you have a little guy right i
do i do have a little guy he's
eddie what do you have i have a little
guy as well my little champ yeah what do
you have
eddie i just said i have a little guy as
well i do not have a little guy
i don't have a pet i have no pet from my
memory from my memory
from my memory i think bloody has a
hamster
i think we don't vote and we just get
them next time you can't lie about this
because if
if she's lying then we immediately know
yeah yeah
terrible idea killing mark first because
he filibusts for so long
mark would be really great imposters
yeah he could watch you kill someone and
be like i was doing my test
down on the ranch me and mrs maysville
shared a picture of iced tea we all used
to have hamsters all right um
i've got my
no hamster gang let's go it's
eddie it's zoe it's eddie [ __ ]
i saw ethan drop right next to him i'm
so sorry that i wasn't muted
chris oh that's okay i i expected you
guys to see it immediately chris you
didn't spoil anything
i didn't say anything that round because
i knew i could get a kill
so um [ __ ] it it's uh trevor's my boy
he's the other imposter trust my words
guys
um all right i'll see you is he telling
the truth or is he lying
no i'm not confused the seat of doubt is
planted i don't know guys
also when you guys said little guy i
genuinely thought you were just saying a
cute way for hamster so i didn't think i
was lying there
i thought you heard the thing you had
your little guy hamsters just a little
guy
you're gonna you're gonna learn to throw
him in the vent first eddie
chubby amazing
amazing oh very funny very funny stuff
very good stuff uh very good stuff
very funny stuff anyway um yeah
i've been i've been crew for so many
times yes
but i don't care for everyone who's just
like oh man he's never been impossible
i'm fine with that i am so good i'm 100
okay it's not that i can't lie it's just
that like
i'm having just a good time doing my
tasks and if i'm imposter i can't do
tasks and that just feels wrong
you know what i mean that just feels
wrong
bing okay yeah i'm done okay well i
guess i just sit around and wait
has anyone been killing anybody
anyone been killing anybody
[Music]
how's everyone doing um
without walking where i did what do you
mean i saw you at the top
and then i walked down to the cafeteria
and then you came up from the bottom
no i didn't i walked there hey you're
trev but
i saw a lot of people on my way what i
mean
did you drop your fun dip down event
i just wanted wait we got two venting
accusations now
we've
trevor where did you take then no i was
just finding my fun dip
amber do you see him bent or are you
just goofing no no i saw him
stand on it look back look back at me
and then just stand there and i thought
um this is a bit oh did he use it
no we're just okay okay
we could vote bloody and then trevor
next round if we wanted me
i don't know it was bloody i think that
would be an awesome sauce
excuse me what did you say something
about awesome sauce awesome
he said awesome sauce i might have to
vote travel on this one
that's a big towel i mean he's an
awesome sauce i'm sorry
that's kind of weird this is a terrible
idea the game doesn't end i do think
it's bloody
okay yeah i guess i'm we heard two vent
accusations and i don't know the map
wait wait wait wait wait what what it's
i don't think trevor did anything what i
don't think it's just
i'm pretty positive no no no it's okay
it's okay you get to eat more fun dip
i don't have a bunny why did we do that
i don't understand that's sad but i
think the
crew's gonna win anyway just because the
tasks are almost done so it's just a
matter of time
i'm hunting you it's me
from the beyond all right that's bloody
we could we win
okay listen wait what yes yes
okay listen yes okay okay if eddie was
not called out
immediately he would have been shot okay
because he said awesome sauce yeah
that's true that's true that's true
sorry trevor you were just eating your
fun dip my best
yeah oh my god no he's good because he
got to eat more
do we want to do original map or keep
doing this one more
i'd be down to the original map for like
two more rounds
yeah yeah yeah so we're back to this
are we interesting oh this
garbage literally this garbage why are
there leaves in here anyway
i would love to be able to find a bo i
haven't found a body in ages i've only
been
body just bend body maybe i expose
myself to be a body too much
is there such a thing as defensive play
i'm going to play defensively
what a sticky situation oh my god
wow sticky
electrical on the lights they killed her
after she turned them on
that's a shame all right
there's no one else in the room
no one was in the room i think that they
vented in possibly
was it front or back it was at the light
switch she turned them on and then died
i can't believe they made her do the
task and then slaughtered her there
they let her turn the lights on first
yeah she did one final good deed
do you guys just want to do soul read
and vote someone off the killer just
wanted to
yeah there might be a vibe
or security to confirm no one vented
from there
nope no okay well i think we don't know
anything then
okay great cool it's only one that's
about it only one dead
numbers are okay
[Music]
wait that's very suspicious normally you
would ramble on yeah
all right there's nothing to say okay
okay people want more
give me a chance all right so
something suspicious i'm gonna be
sus to ethan
really sizing him up oh look at me
playing lately
what a lady
i'm sussin all over him i'm gonna suss
all over him
my monologue
they were just trying to stop
my monologue how dare they
next time i will monologue
all right i think i saw a murder
i just stumbled across a body with chris
yeah so i think oh wait wait wait
we can literally we can literally find
out where everyone is brian you were
with me eddie where were you
just now i was in the right side of the
map i think i ended up maybe around
shield
all i need to know shovel where were you
okay i'm in storage
so i was in weapons i believe the ghost
of mark is here
amber where were you uh i was just
trying to do card swipe don't mind me
okay ethan i was in the hallway uh
in between like comms and weapons oh
ethan
so disappointed wait chris i'm confused
did you believe
shelby about brian i think it's yeah i
guess
on him i saw i saw why are you always
on me i saw a dark grey character kill
in front of me and i'm pretty sure it
was ethan dude
oh okay the only reason i said brian was
because i liked
him and it was going with him standing
there for a very long time i did not see
ethan at all no it was ethan i think
dude okay
but wait hold on chris were you with
anybody
yeah with brian right behind you yeah
yeah i literally walked up to the body
at the same time
wait so shelby why do you say that you
think it's brian
he was doing topo too but he wasn't
doing it he was the only one standing
there because i was literally just
typing in the numbers
i'm just saying you were there for a
long time kind of letting it run
i wasn't saying it was you know the
numbers could be confusing somebody they
are
they are like not in order that's
confusing i can believe that but then
chris said he believed me so
i don't know okay brian but can you
confirm
that chris
wait really why i was gonna skip i did
skip
well well well he wasn't the one
that killed me but he watched it happen
he saw how could he me
the man who does stuff occasionally
who occasionally has the wherewithal
to do proper tasks is
me that guy the one who does
things such as the that oh yeah
no ethan is um quite suspicious most of
the time
oh my god yo so so i have
i have a um theory okay okay i found
this body in storage the only person i
think it could potentially be is eddie
because he was the last person i saw
walking away from it
i saw brian walking in that direction
beforehand
i passed brian in that hallway before
that chris well he was stuck in he was
he was stuck in electrical though yeah
chris and i were on opposite sides of
the door when it locked in
electrical okay then i don't know
because i was i was walking that way but
i was in reactor for forever
well and trevor uh by uh security so i
feel like they're good
but it might either be brian or eddie i
think we get 50 50 this is either it has
to be either yeah it has to be or it
could be
chris doing his software but i'm
confident we've got ethan
ethan so i think we're good i got ethan
eddie or brian well do you want to do
like a good old soul read who do you
think brian or eddie what do you guys
give a good soul i believe you but i
think it's you
i said we go for eddie maybe or brian i
don't know i don't know
60 seconds suggestions that's an eddie
and brian because i'm sick
i saw brian sticking around in that
direction that's all i saw i was in
electrical
and then ran upper left to finish the
little crystal turny thing
he did go left because i passed him
there's a chance that eddie walked by
brian while he
well he just finished a kill and then
brian went up to electrical and then he
got stuck in there quote unquote
okay what's the other theory against
eddie though because now i feel like
there's bias
i mean we don't we don't have to vote
here actually no i think we should vote
because
then we should we call another meeting
right and then we've all reached this
one
trevor trevor here's the deal we call a
meeting
and um we get it i'm voting brian
i'd say you were dead to me but i'm dead
oh my god i was running
i think it's trevor man i think it's
trevor
and she'll hear out my reasons sorry
i'll hear you out trevor's been trying
to bribe us with candy this entire night
come on dude don't you have a sweet
tooth man shelby
you could vote me but what if you voted
trevor think about that
well that's not it i want candy
well she's right eddie you're pretty
close man
yeah dude well can i ask ethan why did
you say you can vote me this first time
oh my god because i'm a [ __ ]
and you're like yeah you guys you can
vote me i'm like you're leaving me out
here with everybody else i'm
sorry anyone else do i see amber for
half the [ __ ] mountains
eddie you were stopping me from my
monologue that's the only reason and i
know it is i'm very sorry the way it's
worked out
yeah it's okay because i'm gonna milk
this next one
why am i always being sussed i'm sorry
immediately
all it takes is shelby going i i'm
suffering brian and i go why and she
goes
uh because i kind of saw you in an area
that was sort of near a body
and then everyone goes what's up right
now you i just said you were suspicious
what is this oh well that's that
easy
all right all right one
leaf two leaf three leaves
four leaves five
leaves hang on hang on i have
information i'm just trying to pull up
the map to make sure okay okay
i was chris was in communications
right before me i walk out of
communications and all i see is brian's
dead body
mm-hmm i think i'm stuck on brian i
noted
wait
because i didn't even see that body
you're the only person that i saw
in that area and then i walk out of that
room and a body is dead right outside
the doorway that's
not saying that you did it
it's not me i i feel like i don't really
sound like it's convincing but it's not
me
i was uh in i was doing oh i think one
task in communications i went to storage
who's laughing who's gay looks for me
i'm giggling because the first thing
that you said was
that's so weird
[Laughter]
yo here's the deal here's your straight
up it's not me um
but like obviously it looks shitty you
could let me do my task and then we'll
win
so what are we doing the leaves
they were just turning a lovely shade of
brown must be fall back on earth
been away from home for so long haven't
seen terra firma
getting space madness maybe we're all
killers deep down
and we're just waiting for the moment to
snap but did anyone see anyone else
walking between storage and shields
no because that's all we can identify
right past
mark so i can at least say it's not him
this time i'm gonna i think it's mario
because he hasn't gotten it do you i
mean i guess it could be but i don't
know i saw him at that i think he was
coming from
vote cafeteria so i don't think mark did
this talking about space madness what if
we all have could be
that could all any one of us could be a
murderer
just waiting for the right moment to
snap
that is the game mark you're right
is this a who killed markiplier did you
guys hear kristen he's keeping my eye on
his eye on me he didn't see me the whole
round what the [ __ ] are you talking
about
interesting chris okay what was i doing
i've got three tasks in electrical
i don't trust ethan but i'm gonna make
him
suspicious what if i just stalk him
just watch him i'm just gonna look at
him
just looking at him
just watching him just looking at him
one can't be too careful
all right i found a body mark you were
chasing me that whole time and you just
standing there when we were in nav
why were you just standing there that
was weird because i was watching you
i liked the way you moved and it seemed
like you did tasks
but also on top of that i too
had the task of navigation hmm which one
the shippy dotted liney
can't a man have a lunch break
why'd you vote so fast because mark was
following me around a lot
and mark didn't seem like he was doing
tasks and there was a lot of times where
it would have been a good opportunity to
kill me but then at the last second
somebody else walked in
and that i feel it makes me
uncomfortable and also mark hasn't been
now listen chris's body was
over in reactor and mark was chasing me
and i reported it as fast as i could
because i was afraid of being killed by
the man
with long hair look okay
there are many men with longer hair than
i but you
cannot make an accusation when i was
watching you wait what are we doing
i don't know i think we're thinking oh
that was close i i almost accidentally
[ __ ] voted for eddie there too it
clicked eddie and i was like
i'm keeping my peepers on mars i'm
keeping my peepers on
you
[Music]
[Music]
alana just killed ethan right in front
of me
right it was
sort of a payback for the last round if
i'm being honest okay i'm voting
on my birthday
can i say i'm not sad that he's dead
i'm very happy i'm just gonna say to my
other imposter like that
it cannot be done they have too many
tasks that they can finish i was like
why [ __ ] there's no way
we can win this other criminals so you
gotta [ __ ] kill
everybody uh mock if you could kill more
people i don't think
that would be really helpful i'm looking
at amber bloody and trevor
declare my innocence
there's only one they got the way that
that is
no because i'm not the imposter
fascinating
not the imposter that is something
special
o2 oh we got to get to that that's like
a
thing nope oh my god
we gotta go oh we got it okay cool
i'm so close i think it might be shovel
no
can i say what i just saw yeah i was on
cam's
amber walked up to the body and walked
away i want nothing to do with it
i saw her outside my background oh my
god
that's very interesting did you walk up
on a cold body
yeah uh well so i saw shovel come down
going to cams and then i went up and
then she started following me
and then i found because i saw the body
on the camera
and then i saw the body near med that's
a good excuse
i don't know for sure that it's amber
but she did whatever
you ever think you did walk away from
the body when you saw it
look i didn't want it
you know because i had one toss left i
just went
trevor yeah i voted amber okay it's
not me though she just did not want to
touch that body
oh my god we're about to be in the game
so aren't we
i don't know oh my goodness i just had
to say that that happened
i'm sorry
let me get this done
then run away from everybody just run
run away i mean i guess we can call a
meeting
comms are sabotaged that's not good
[Music]
oh no
[Music]
okay my task you're done
eddie trevor hmm
all right so what are we doing here
i am pretty much 100 positive it's not
mark
because we were doing even the same task
at some point i've been alone with him a
ton during this game
thank you trevor and shelby trevor you
came back and clicked the button
shelby where did you go during any of
that i went back onto cameras but then
the comms never got fixed so i started
going towards comms i'm outside
electricity now
interesting training comes
because i wanted to call emergency
because i think it might be you shovel
but
it might be mark i don't know what you
have to say
mark there is no way that it's me and
i'll tell you why
that'd be [ __ ] quick buddy because i
didn't kill anybody
there you go i mean okay but you were
with him the last round but no one died
this round anyway
yeah i'm saying even before we were
electrical alone for a long time
downloading we're both an admin alone
uploading
like it's okay if it is then it's a
really careful game but also
what if what if eddie's just playing
this really smart right now trevor i'm
not
ever okay guys i want to note that
trevor's now excuse me all right
just accused all three of us at one
point and trevor found the last body
i will say this i have seen
eddie i've seen you around
the ones that i have not been around a
lot
are shovel and trevor of the two of
those
i only saw trevor towards the end and he
hit the emergency button
better to play it without killing
someone
as opposed to calling a meeting right
or isn't that the smart play if you were
in an intelligence
who are we voting if we're voting for
someone i think we skipped
wrong we're dead right here
i'm going to punch you in your achilles
heel buddy if you don't vote
trevor i'm trying to figure out okay
we'll win dude you got played
oh wait just kidding
all right sorry trevor about pointing
fingers just because
i thought you were really intelligent
there but i'm not smart enough to make
that call
and it was the last thing shovels said
that i was like oh it's trouble
i i will say that the most jarring part
about that round was mark actually
playing the game at the
that was the most surprising part well i
i would have played the game but
i've been dead every time
last game best game gamers didn't want
to do it
let's go
no i don't want to go to all electrical
i just saw trevor i just saw i just saw
trevor kill
uh bloody are you kidding me there's
like four people there
can confirm just came off of a task
jesus christ
can confirm there were four people or
can confirm trevor
can confirm uh there's a dead body
okay well it's just a group of people i
think it's trevor
uh i'm almost positive that it's trevor
because i think the other person that
was over there which i think was
eddie was doing the task no i wasn't nav
and brian was just saw me oh was it
amber who you [ __ ] saw it was
a green it was a green person amber so
it was you
no i just literally did wires huh
no no that's what i mean is you were
doing wires in storage right
yeah okay you were doing wires in
storage so you wait so ethan
and the other person was trevor and i
saw a body fall and trevor was right
next to it
and i saw it
i feel like if ethan was the imposter he
wouldn't be throwing
accusations at two people when he thinks
it's not early but also i don't want to
throw if it is ethan so
let's keep also the last game though he
could have gone chaotic
what i [ __ ] saw my easter egg was her
body right
all right he's a [ __ ] body this
bloody body
falling to the ground what i see is a
green man
and an orange man what happened i don't
know
who i don't know he's little
four people no
amber why did you get trevor because i
was standing there and there's only two
other people
i'm so confused okay
i don't trust anyone in that that trio
it's
[ __ ] weird hmm fascinating
where am i oh my tests are all the way
in navigation
[Music]
hmm
where be the body all right i'm
reporting the body again i know that
makes me look
looks us it's real sus but i'm not gonna
walk into admin find a body and then
walk out because that would be
not great did get amber last time yeah
uh so i saw i saw shelby in uh
admin only person i saw an admin was
chris when i was doing card swipe i went
down
into electrical where i have four
different tasks it's a lot of detail
um i was in med bay i saw amber there i
was just leaving
and to walk down and i walked into
storage so i guess i walked past admin
but i definitely didn't go in there
where were you at and also chris
cafeteria i just finished a tuscan
cafeteria and then had to go to the
other side i was
about to head to memphis i was in that
place
and i did um the leaves and i could say
mark was with me
dawson leaves out into the space chris
is the only question that i also saw in
the cafeteria
so did anyone walk into admin like mid
game at all
no that was late game when i uh chris uh
left after me that's the only thing i
saw
i'm concerned that ethan has been like
last game baby chaos
that's what's happening yeah
i'm scared so i'm going to say something
in the in the last 15 seconds
i'm still voting trevor again because i
literally [ __ ] saw him
kill bloody oh my god oh my god so
that's what i'm doing because i don't
have anything else i'm just going to do
this
because i think it's funny i hate that
that's for sure
what the heck what the hell
[Laughter]
we didn't count out how many leaves
very suspicious very suspicious
i honestly wonder if it's ethan because
if he was in a clump and he decided to
like just
throw utter chaos into the mix he would
like just use the chaos of the whole
group being there to be like oh
what the hell you know what i mean it
would be strange
oh that's not good
am i a dead man oh no i'm okay
apparently it's just i'm standing over
by the vent is just a little bit like
fiddle dee dee
no they might be okay
oh my [ __ ] god
thank you triple and you saw him kill
someone and we did it anyway
are you guys chill with one more yeah
yeah yeah yeah
that was that was by accident ethan i
was like
he's suspicious and then you were the
first person i saw already spam the
button i was like well i was ethan
that's my bad but i guess we wanted
anything damn
that was that was quick damn that was
quick good work trevor
thank you ethan i believe you dude i'm
sorry thank you so much i
appreciate it kill me there sorry we
ever doubted you good luck
okay this time i'm actually going to try
to pay attention to who's where
pallet is in the cafeteria brian went
out right alana was doing a task up
there
lana's doing the test bloodies of the
weapons
okay so palada
and bloody and alana alana made sense
going right to where that was
palada was in the cafeteria not doing
anything
okay there's a lot i'm i'm thinking that
alana and i have similar
tasks there's brian don't trust brian
not even a little bit bloody seemed like
in the right spot
yeah don't trust oops
imagine my surprise when i walk into the
cafeteria
oh my god ready to go get some food
after a long day's work and i'm fine
i just want to remind you guys
anyway cafeteria bottom left is anybody
in the cafe
i'm an adult yeah did you see anybody i
saw nobody around
when i found the body okay i only saw a
marker player going up from i think
uh o2 into cafeteria so i don't think he
could have done a self-report plus i
don't think he's capable
oh my god we could do a soul read here i
don't know why everyone's right
what is up with you in [ __ ] reading
what were you doing when you walked in
the room and then you just [ __ ]
pieced out of the room and you didn't do
anything in the room
you walked into the room with me and
then you left the room we were in adam
no
oh oh i actually don't know i guess i
thought i had a test in there but i
didn't
i don't remember hmm i have more
information if you want it
from my incapable chris you voted quick
are you voting no no no hang on what
what who are you
alana is fine she seemed to have the
same task that i did
bloody was right at weapons paladin was
in the cafeteria when we
alana and i were both there i went down
brian was standing by the shields bottom
right
after i went there i looped a background
through weapons two cafeteria found the
body
paladin was doing nothing that i saw why
can you not be this succinct all the
time
i never saw but i don't trust for some
reason my
i think a man who eats fun dip really
sad
for not being able to do a self report
okay it's not mock and i almost want to
stick with mom you're not muted alana
oh sorry guys hey it's not mock though
just so everyone knows
fascinating there's trevor hmm
trouble going right pallad at the right
location
let me just double check yes palette
it's okay brian
moving up towards cafeteria bloody over
to the right bottom
don't trust that alana and pallid going
both going up there pallid head coming
after me
powder's definitely coming after me
[Music]
oh i saw shovel kill and self-report
there was another body too
oh my god trevor kills in front of me
oh my god my word against his i don't
know why you're laughing when he later
saw you killing self report instantly
okay hold on wait where was it in admin
yeah i was an admin where she's going to
do my wires because i did my wires and
electrical first and i went over to do
wires and admin and he killed me right
now you can do wires when you're
imposter
why are you laughing i literally saw you
murder a man
self-report and blame an innocent person
such as myself
first of all i don't know why they'll be
referring to the entrance of admin
anyway
shelby could have killed me i wanted to
no i think you could strive
to work it's true that you're blaming me
he stabbed brian right in the hall like
entrance doorway of admin and then
so the only the only thing is
that shelby and i don't mean to call you
out i've known you for a very long time
and your your voice is a little weird
right now
i i can't please someone's blaming you
i fully think no i mean i've been
waiting in a room for a while there uh
mark you were alone in a room with
shelby
and i just walked in and oh yeah you
guys weren't electrical together
oh heck yeah actually i only stepped
into electrical i saw
shelby standing over the vent but not
necessarily
it might have been the download i saw
top right corner she was up there i
didn't want a chance it went back down i
came around palada was being a little
suspicious
like creeping up on me but didn't commit
to anything there was another body which
was chris was
okay of the ship do we know anything
about chris where he was last night
chris i was just showing chris's body no
was in the top left over there
i don't trust trevor for a second but
ethan does know who and mark were
good if shovel knows if ethan knows
troubles
tell i would be willing to trust that
however
you think shelby's getting played i 100
believe that
i kind of agree i'd be sure i don't want
to
i don't care okay trevor it's trouble
i [ __ ] hope i'm right but i think
that shelby has just [ __ ] fun
i do have a thing to say mark is talking
way more this round
but i i don't know if that actually
means anything i have no idea
he might just be playing the game now
because he's alive [ __ ] mistake
no i mean if you want a 50 50 s i don't
care
i think no i think you're good okay
so of the people that i think it is it's
definitely not
ethan it's definitely not uh
alana but it could be it could be
shoveled definitely like we might have
been wrong about that paladab was being
a little bit
a little bit suspicious wait what did
paladin just do why did she go the
bottom
right of of uh oops
why did she just go to the bottom what
would she have to do on the bottom of
okay bloody just passing me by did not
kill me bloody going right
alana and electrical that's fine and now
she's dead
i didn't think it was shelby didn't
think it was shelby wow this is some
unfortunate events um i was right i
didn't see anything or anyone but i did
see shelby's thick hand butt
so we're at oh you saw it this time huh
you couldn't see mine
last night look okay wait hold on where
is it
near security so it's like right out the
front so she was going to look at cams
she had she was going to collect
evidence and now she's dead
this is fascinating because bloody
passed me right by bottom right
like around towards the end so i was
going the complete opposite direction
but far enough away that it was
justifiable alana i think you're clear
definitely
paladin you were pretty pretty okay you
had opportunities to come after me you
didn't
ethan what's your justification and
where were you what's my justification
i went up in clear bloody for the record
i can clear bloody i think also i can
clearly
how can you clear bloody is my question
i was just asking where were you i
went into electrical uh and then i went
up into
top reactor and then i was going back
into cafeteria at the end of the game
that would put you in the right spot to
kill this person wait so mark why did
you
why did you clear amber though wait hey
i'm just saying
i don't clear amber i clear bloody i
clear you
i don't clear amber just because uh she
had opportunities but didn't pursue them
i don't know foreign at all
i haven't seen ethan either that is the
one person i haven't seen
anywhere so what do you mean you haven't
seen me mark
well you saw me in storage i didn't see
you in storage did you see me in storage
i saw you in storage this round here's
what we do guys we vote out ethan right
now and if it's not ethan we go and we
uh call a meeting and it's amp i agree i
agree
done tight work
[Laughter]
i feel like i got [ __ ] over here it's
my birthday
yeah let's go oh my god that med bay
kill i dipped
i was leaving and came out of nowhere
and i was slamming to click the button
and he [ __ ] killed me on my way there
i was telling
him oh holy [ __ ]
yeah way better at lying i'm just going
to say that yeah he really feels way
better
i've gotten better at lying yeah
violently like you used to be like
what are you asking me for
the only reason i i suspected you after
that is because
you you earlier in the games every time
it was you
you would distract people by immediately
accusing asking someone else where they
were when they asked you and you
wouldn't answer the question
right
as a detective to the last two games
becoming a real detective
i remember everything that happened it
was amazing amazing
so good so damn good listen
i play stupid for a bit
but i'm not stupid i see everything
not capable of self-reporting
[Music]
you